[Applaudissements]
merci ma chérie vous avez pas céder sa
copie followers alors j'ai deux trucs
dit moi je vais faire un truc soit je
vais faire une proposition en direct à
d'autres des animateurs dites moi et tu
me dit s'il entendait sûrs et ce que je
peut engager deux des animateurs pour
jouer au théâtre
bien sûr tous les soirs à la madeleine à
plein de la rentrée puisque vous êtes
libre je le fais tu direct là tout de
suite
l'ensemble de la proposition aux deux
les deux me disent s'ils veulent ou
s'ils veulent pas c'est normal je peux
tout vous dire après allez-y vous est
proposée à camille combal enora malagré
joue au théâtre sinon s'il te plaît non
non c'est là alors je vous le dis dès
lors à enora c'est bon camille combal
il s'attaque à rentrer à quelle heure à
la maison cette affaire 23h à non alors
non j'ai ma vie non mai et décidera
lui-même non mais c'est vrai c'est pas
mal c'est 2-2 après l'audition à la
direction de télévision en ligne c'est
énorme
alors il aura jonas ou non il n'aurait
qu'à écrire une casse ou
[Applaudissements]
cet effort mondial je vais pas dire à tv
suit pas ça et là mais ça c'est énorme
les jardiniers si tu veux camille bocaly
est mon cas mais aussi donnera sa
réponse je suis moins chaud parce que
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui voit là qui
travaille beaucoup il aura une heure à
21h mai 21h 21h l'année prochaine avec
ce qu'il va faire à moi ça veut dire je
t'ai pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elora salles en mai avec camille combal
et là je vous le dirai bientôt camille
combal il a des gros dossiers à la
rentrée c'est lui qui décide
merci à balles au dos sinon c'était vous
raconter une histoire qui nous fait
mourir de rire et qu'on peut manger des
fois avec cette histoire des lésions va
voir oui